it's it's super frustrating when people
don't have any idea as to what they're
applying for
I'm a recruiter I've been recruiting in
New York City for about six years and
this is what you need to know to get
hired when we get a resume we get it
super excited got a great position open
my VP comes to me and it goes oh my god
this is the guy we have contacts at said
companies that this person has worked at
come to find out this person never
worked there someone told us that they
graduated with a bachelor's degree we
ended up doing a background check it
came back that they didn't go to college
at all
and we had to rescind the offer don't
lie first off a resume should always be
one page I always recommend that your
resume should not be longer than two
pages most important information on the
top right things are you're most proud
about and then what's your work
experience when I see fonts like Comic
Sans wing-dings
any sort of weird formatting symbolism
in your resume I am probably not going
to move you forward the worst ones are
ones that either are way too complicated
and have too much information that have
nothing to do with what I'm looking for
or they're too simplified I literally
got a resume once that said I don't need
a resume my background will speak for
itself
call me worst phone calls are when you
get on the phone
why'd you apply what do you know about
my company and you have nothing
absolutely do your research it's so
important get on Glassdoor get on their
website
[Music]
if you're sick do not come into a job
interview there's this one time I was
confirming an interview and they told me
they were like okay I have pinkeye I'm
gonna wear an eye patch I hope that's
okay totally okay she ended up coming in
and she didn't wear an eye patch just
call out to stay home don't come in with
pinkeye I work in an office that is I'll
call it business comfortable I want you
to represent that I want you to feel
like you could slide in and and that's
what we're looking for visually but I
would probably research and go on to the
LinkedIn page and the company's page to
see how they dress if we were super
casual and you're coming in with a
three-piece suit probably not gonna work
out it's too damn much don't do that
don't do that
when we ask about your greatest weakness
usually I'm just asking to see like how
honest you are with yourself things that
will help me understand that you are
generally paying attention to who your
inner person is that's important to hear
a good answer for your weakness should
be genuine what is an actual weakness
that you want to work on and tell us how
and why so for example if your greatest
weakness is that you can't get up on
time you should finish your answer by
saying that's my weakness but this is
what I'm doing to work on it the first
conversation I have with candidates
always about money
there is a line right like there's a cap
and then there's a floor if you want 20
grand more than the job offers then
that's a conversation you should happen
the very beginnings there's full
transparency between all parties you're
not getting underpaid right so imagine
like a tree you might fit in the middle
right and if that middle let's just call
it $50,000 I can't give you $30,000
because I think I can negotiate you
there because the people that you're
gonna be sitting across and beside they
all make $50,000 so if you tell me you
need $100,000 I'm gonna go I'm not gonna
work because I know what everyone else
is making I need you to fit kind of in a
similar bucket right make sure you have
at least three questions at the end of
your conversation to ask the recruiter I
think a really good question to ask at
the end of an interview is what can I do
in this role in the first three months
to be successful what does like the
first 30 to 90 days look like in this
job I think that gives you the perfect
framework for what you can do in the
future if you get the job you'll
basically have a cheat sheet for what
you need to do in your first couple
months
[Music]
[Applause]
if you don't get the job don't don't
stock me it's over the stalker scenario
is when a candidate does not understand
why they didn't get the job and they
follow you on Instagram they follow you
on Facebook I definitely had a guy and
this guy could not let it go he showed
up to the office wanting to talk to me a
connection on LinkedIn fine that's cool
but that's anything more than that you
cross the line I get not a Facebook
message not an Instagram message key
messages me on LinkedIn and asks me out
on a date after we turned up down for an
interview he did not get the job and he
definitely did not get the date keep
reaching out to people on LinkedIn keep
expanding your network there is a job
out there for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]